all right playing Coffee House
hey it's vampire chicken
oh I should update the Vegas command
there's a new update
we should start uh start promoting
there's gonna be a mysterious person
taking over my twitch channel for some
of the games during Vegas
maybe not so mysterious
and maybe not a person could be a
vampire and or a chicken hey it's a
opening trap
so many people are falling for this
like I've had this a good handful of
times in the last week or two
so the the point is that once B7 hangs
then the night is hanging
and then the bishop is hanging
oh no mercy
okay
I want to make this a standalone YouTube
video
how to beat an I am in 11 moves with the
London it's a nasty trap
Bishop A6 Bishop A6 Works in that
position but also if if Bishop D6 here
this is also winning
it's a really really nice trap
so if you're watching in the future on
YouTube
I'm playing a tournament coming up in
Vegas
it's a super Swiss 1000 GM
it starts on Thursday June 8th I'm
flying out very soon
and for many of the rounds of the
tournament the one and only vampire
chicken
will be taking over this twitch channel
so this is a website there's a big prize
fund
the fnd 500 for first
it's going to be a nine round classical
event there are Norm possibilities so if
I do really well maybe I can
come a step closer to the GM title but
I'm just looking to play good chess and
have fun
uh there's a lot of strong players
this is a sign up list
Gilead niznik is his top seed
26.54 I'm pretty sure he's top 100 in
the world uh there's at least a dozen
GMS
actually it says here 12 GMS
you have to scroll down to find my name
my video rating is actually a little bit
lower I lost points from Reykjavik
I'm not sure if that's updated yet
and there's 77 players total if this
video is on YouTube I'll leave links in
the video description and then after
this tournament there's going to be
another event it's a Vegas chess
Festival
and for anyone that might be
thinking about visiting
uh it's not too late to sign up Vegas
chessfestival.com
I'll be giving
a couple simuls
I'll be doing a meet and greet I'll be
playing Blitz with people
should be a fun event it starts June
14th
so again all information in the twitch
chat and in the future YouTube video
description